when it comes to the constants of nature
we don't have any probability
distribution so if someone makes a
statement like it seems to be very
unlikely that the constants of nature
would just have exactly the values that
we do have that's a completely
meaningless statement because we can't
quantify this probability
[Music]
so we'll continue with the question was
the universe made for us to which I
think the answer is no for we currently
know
so first I think I have to put this
question into a context physicists as I
said we don't really like to talk about
life and so on
but in cosmology we often talk about the
preconditions for life for example a
carbon is often used as a precondition
for life but some of you may think maybe
this is already too specific at the very
least you'd need something like a
sufficiently complex chemistry or indeed
the possibilities for any structures
form in the universe uh and this is all
not life in and by itself but it's
something that we believe to be
necessary for life to ever come into
being
and um so the reason
um physicists talk about this uh this
question like was the universe
especially made for us like do we have a
special place in this universe comes
from the observation that
um for some slight changes to the
constants of nature
um it would not be possible for
structures to even form it would not be
possible to form a carbon or any kind of
sufficiently large molecule the most
famous example uh may be the structure
of the carbon nucleus which is a
prediction that was made by Fred Hoyle
so he figured out that for carbon to be
produced in Stars the carbon nucleus had
to have a particular structure it had to
have a particular resonance and that was
later actually discovered
um so I think one way to look at this
kind of prediction is to say that
the observation that we ourselves exist
is also an observation and that is good
for some things for example for the
observation that it must be possible for
stars to produce carbon
there are some other examples where some
changes to properties of the constants
of nature or nuclear and so on would
eradicate Life as we know it a
particularly simple to understand
example is the cosmological constant so
the cosmological constant is that thing
which makes the universe expand and
actually makes the expansion of the
universe accelerate so if the
cosmological constant was very large
then it basically immediately rip apart
all the structures in the universe so
stars and galaxies could never form this
is if the value is positive if the
values are large and negative
so the absolute value is large but the
sign is negative then the universe would
immediately recollapse after the big
bang so again there's no way that
structures could have formed
um so again we we see that just the
observation that we exist or else this
sounds tells us something about the
cosmological constant it's a similar
story for Newton's constants the
Newton's constant sets the strength of
gravity uh If gravity is too strong then
Stars burn out too quickly and so on and
so forth um there are lots of books that
have been written about this I'm not
going to go through the entire list of
examples they all basically work the
same way you take a particular concept
of nature you make a small change to it
you figure out what happens to all the
physical processes that we know of and
then you figure out that some of the
preconditions for life are no longer
fulfilled which brings up the question
can this possibly be a coincidence it
looks as though making these small
changes makes it appear very unlikely
that our universe would have had just
exactly the right values for the
constants of nature so that life can
exist so there's a big problem with this
argument which is that if you're talking
about the probability of something you
have to quantify this probability so
normally when we talk about the
probability of say throwing throwing dye
we have a probability distribution that
in principle we can either derive from a
model for the die or we can just collect
it by throwing dire many times and
collecting the data so we know it's 1 6
for each of the different phases to come
up
but when it comes to the constants of
nature we don't have any probability
distribution so if someone makes a
statement like it seems to be very
unlikely that the constants of nature
would just have exactly the values that
we do have that's a completely
meaningless statement because we can't
quantify this probability
so it's not a scientific argument you
know you could certainly say and people
have made this argument based on
Bayesian probabilities I find it
surprising that the values of the
constants are so as to allow for the
existence of life and that's fine you
know you're free to find surprising
whatever you want but it's not a
scientific argument there is another
issue with this argument which is uh for
one it's just wrong and that may be it
it may cause someone else a surprise
because some of those topics that we
talk about in the foundational physics
it seems that nothing ever changes you
know we've been talking about some of
those things uh for hundreds of years
like determinism in determinism nature
of time uh and so on but this is this is
an example where people have actually
um come up with new arguments uh for
example
um they figured out that they're
actually other combinations of the
constants of nature that do seem to
allow for the preconditions of life in
some form and those are not the same as
in our universe one example as I just
said
um Hoyle figured out that the carbon
nucleus should have a particular
resonance uh so as to for carbon to be
produced in stars but there are other
possibilities uh other ways you can make
this uh happen and uh recently someone
have has come up with a different way to
do it where the concepts of nature are
not the ones that we have in our
universe there are also people who have
argued that we actually don't really
need What's called the weak nuclear
force so the weak nuclear force is one
of the fundamental interactions that we
know of it's responsible for example for
radioactive decay
and some people have argued that we
actually don't need it to create all
those structures that we see in the
universe they call this universe without
the weak uh without the weak force and
they say in such a universe you'd still
be able to to produce sufficiently
complex chemical structures so it just
seems that it's just not the case that
there's only one particular combination
of those constants
I also think that part of the reason why
physicists fall for this kind of
argument like the universe is really
really special and we need this exact
combination of constants is that they
tend to think that complexity is rare
you know it takes something to create it
whereas I think it's exactly the
opposite like complexity is the thing
that we generically get if we combine
all those physical processes and this is
actually an argument which was made
beautifully in Stuart Kaufman in his
book at home in the universe he
basically says if you if you combine
sufficiently many things and you just
give it time and complexity uh will come
out of it I think that physicists kind
of they're not familiar talking about
complexity at all so for them this kind
of thinking is a little bit alien but I
believe if we understand better how
complexity comes about and how chaos
works and all that kind of thing we'll
probably find there are many other
examples of combinations of constants of
nature that would also give rise to
preconditions for life so I really think
it's more likely to be the rule than the
exception so was the universe made for
us for we currently know no
so let me come to these two copies of us
exist so this is really a question about
the Multiverse and I would say that's an
example of a question which is a
scientific
um to use the word from my friend Palmer
which he brought this up in an interview
that I did with him and I just took it
and ran away with it
okay so
um again I think I first have to explain
why would someone even come up with this
idea that copies of us exist that sounds
certainly a little bit weird but that's
because Infinity is weird so in this
standard model of the universe that we
currently use for cosmology the universe
is infinitely large
um
this by the way is also the case at the
big bang I know that a lot of people
have this idea at the Big Bang the
universe was kind of like a small ball
but that's not quite right so these are
not cosmology the universe is always
infinitely large what happens at the Big
Bang is really that the energy density
becomes uh infinitely large
so but the thing with infinity is that
if you have some kind of density
fluctuations in this in this early
universe and you just
go out all the way to Infinity then any
kind of fluctuation will happen
somewhere with probability one that's
what Infinity does to you
now our solar system our galaxy and you
and I everything we know
um grew out of this early hot Plasma in
the universe with those small density
fluctuations in them so if you have an
infinitely large Universe then those
density fluctuations they will repeat
with arbitrarily small changes to them
so there would be a version of Earth
that's exactly the same as ours in every
detail except that there was maybe one
cosmic ray that didn't come down exactly
the same way and it didn't damage
someone's DNA and your neighbor is still
alive or something like this so all
those variations
should actually exist in an infinitely
large universe
um but the problem is the speed of light
is finite and we cannot communicate uh
with anything that's outside what's
called our cosmological Horizon that's
basically anything we can reach uh by
sending signals with the speed of light
or below the problem being that since
the expansion of the universe actually
speeds up it becomes more and more
difficult
to reach other galaxies so they're
basically they're receding faster than
from us than we can possibly communicate
with them
um to make a long story short the the
universe may be infinite and it may have
all those copies of us but we'll never
be able to find out because we can never
interact with them
so there are no observations that can
refute or confirm that these copies
exist
this is one of the simplest version of
what's sometimes called a Multiverse the
one equivalent of whether those are
actually other multiverses another
example is what's called
Eternal inflation
so inflation is one of those theories
for the early universe that I was
talking about the idea is
that there is a new field which fills
the universe this field is called the
inflaton field so and this is the only
thing that exists in the early universe
and the quantum fluctuations in that
field and from those Quantum
fluctuations
um there are bubbles created and those
bubbles expand and give rise to the
universe
um around us now the thing is that
in this infinitely large space there are
lots of those fluctuations again and
those bubbles keep on popping out
forever so there's an infinite number of
big Banks going on in this eternal
inflation scenario and they'll keep on
going on
into all eternity
there are several variations of of this
idea of Eternal inflation for example in
some of those little bubbles that pop
out and grow into universes the
constants of nature could be a little
bit different from the one that we have
here they could also be the same
if if they are different this is often
called the landscape you may have heard
of this as the string theory landscape
so this is actually where the idea comes
from String Theory seems to tell you
that um
the concepts of nature should come with
our possible values so you can combine
this with this idea of Eternal inflation
basically by Distributing the different
values of the constants over the
different big Banks
this is called the Multiverse
though again one can debate whether this
is a particularly good term of course if
you take the word Universe to mean all
that exists then
by definition the Multiverse doesn't
exist which is probably not what the
people who use the term intended
but that's the way that it goes with
nomenclature it doesn't really always
make sense so also in this version of
the Multiverse there should be copies of
us in all those other big bearings
again the problem is though there are no
observations that can recruit to confirm
that these copies exist because we can't
interact with them again you you'd have
to be able to send signals faster than
the speed of light or to transport
yourself faster than the speed of light
to get into one of those other universes
there's a final version of this copy
argument that I want to mention which
you may have heard of that's the many
words interpretation of quantum
mechanics so as I said earlier in
quantum mechanics we have two different
ingredients to the time Evolution we
have the Sharia Evolution and then we
have the measurement update and the
measurement update is indeterministic in
the standard interpretation of quantum
mechanics now in the many worlds
interpretation uh people say well
actually making a measurement does not
collapse the wave function instead what
happens is that the Universe splits each
time you make a measurement so if you
measure the particle
say let's take a simple example where a
particle goes on a screen and you want
to know does it go left or does it go
right in a standard interpretation you
would say well I've measured it the
notes on the left side and that's the
end of the story in the many words
interpretation you would say well now I
have two universes one in which the
particle one to the left side and the
detector says it's on the left side and
one in which it went to the right side
and the cactus has its on the right side
so now we have two universes and this
happens all the time everywhere like
every time some kind of photon bumps
into the wall the universe splits so
there are lots of those universes and
there are copies of us in them
because all those Quantum events happen
around us they even happen in your brain
you know they have every time you turn
on a lamp it's not a rare event so
um though in the many words
interpretation copies of us are all over
the place and our lives pan out in in
all possible ways that they can pan out
um and there are a lot of people in
physics who actually really believe that
this is what's going on
again the problem is though there are no
observations that can refute to confirm
that these copies exist because uh it's
one thing to say okay the universe
splits and all possible outcomes of a
measurement actually do happen in some
universe in our universe we only see one
outcome and that's what we know and so
there's no way to ever figure out if
those other outcomes are actually real
or what it might it doesn't even really
make sense to speak of something being
real if you can't observe it the reason
physicists at least some of them believe
that these copies actually do exist is
the same in all cases they basically
believe that because there are equations
for it it also has to be real so they
have a set of equations they have some
reason to believe that those equations
are correct because they describe
something that we observe
but then uh they jump one step further
and say therefore I believe that
everything which is in those equations
is also real even if I can't
even if I can't observe it
now the problem is
um
that's not a notion of real
anyone ever uses
you know it doesn't really mean anything
to say something is real if if you can't
interact with it if you if you can't
observe it you can just assume that
those mathematical structures are real
but this is an unnecessary hypothesis
you don't need it to describe anything
we observe because it pertains those
parts of the theory that we do not
observe
and as I said earlier we shouldn't use
unnecessary unnecessary hypotheses in
our theories that's just not allowed in
science
so I think these Multiverse arguments
are not proper science
um we can't tell if those copies are
real
so we shouldn't assume that they are
but this doesn't mean that those copies
are not real because science also can
tell you that they do not exist science
doesn't really say anything about it so
if you want to believe that there are
copies of you out there somewhere in the
Multiverse you can believe in this
there's nothing in science that speaks
against it
this brings me to the last question can
particles think
and you won't be surprised to hear that
I think the answer is no so again I
first have to explain why would someone
have this idea to begin with so this I
have to say is uh maybe not so
surprisingly not an idea that's
particularly popular among particle
physicists it enjoys a certain
popularity among philosophers so they
have this idea of pan psychism
everything is a little bit conscious
because it contains something that they
call proto-consciousness and the idea is
that it explains where Consciousness
comes from because you can combine all
those little bits very much like
particle physics and they inform bigger
things like us and at some point the
proto-consciousness combines to what we
normally call Consciousness
now there are different variants of this
argument
one is that this proto-consciousness
isn't a physically real thing so this is
very much like dualism and it doesn't
have any observable consequences to just
like you can say well the mind and the
body is really to separate things
um and this is fine you know it's not in
conflict with science
um this idea of proto-consciousness
without observable consequences
um is also not in conflict with science
but then of course you can't use it to
actually explain what we observe because
it doesn't have any observable
consequences so that that's really I
would say a purely philosophical thing
but there are also some of those pan
psychists or whatever you want to call
them who think that this Consciousness
stuff is actually physically real so
they want to actually use it to explain
Consciousness in the old-fashioned
scientific way now the problem is that
what you're doing then if you're talking
about the properties of the fundamental
constituents of nature you're actually
doing physics and then you talk about
proto-consciousness better Greece with
what we know about the fundamental laws
of nature
so I have to look at this in a little
bit more detail this is what we know
about the fundamental particles in the
world this is basically what everything
is made of
um called the standard model of particle
physics you don't have to count them
there are 25 of them contains good old
friends like the electron and the photon
and the Higgs boson
um the standard mode of particle physics
does not contain composite particles
like protons and neutrons those are made
up of quarks each of them of three
quarts
so um the way that the standard model
Works
um is that each of those particles
um has a set of so-called quantum
numbers of the quantum numbers Define
exactly what the properties of the
particles are quantum numbers one that
you're probably familiar with is the
electric charge some of those particles
have an electric charge some sometimes
it's negative sometimes positive
sometimes it's zero the particles can
also have a spin they have a property
that's called the weak hypercharge it's
basically a more complicated version of
the electric charge the quarks also have
a color and so on and so forth so
there's this set of quantum numbers and
now the way that the standard model
works is that you you take all those
quantum numbers for the particles and
then typically what you want to do is
you want to calculate the results of
some particle collision and what you see
in this picture here this is what
happens if you slam two protons into
each other so this is an image from
Atlas at CERN so the the beams go into
to the screen basically and they run
into each other and then you create a
lot of new particles basically from the
energy in the beams and they go out and
go into different kinds of detectors and
then what they do is they take the
measurements and they detectors and they
reconstruct where the particles came
from and what kind of particles there
were and you compare this with
predictions
so you get you have your data and you
make a calculation for what you expect
with the standard model and that's where
the quantum numbers go in and now the
thing is if there were any other quantum
numbers that those particles had then
the results would just be different
Loosely speaking it's because in quantum
mechanics everything that can happen
does happen so if there were more
quantum numbers than all those different
possible values for the quantum numbers
would also be produced and there'd be
more particles
and we don't see that
so if Elementary particles had any other
internal States and the quantum numbers
that just wouldn't agree with
observation so you can't just say well I
believe that particles have an
additional new property which I call a
proto-consciousness it doesn't really
matter what you call it there isn't any
such property
so project Consciousness can only exist
if it has no physical properties
whatsoever in which case it does not
explain any observations
so parent psychism is popular among some
philosophers so I should probably add
that I'm not opposed to philosophy in
fact I think physicists are not paying
enough attention to philosophy in some
aspects it'll be really really important
for example when it comes to the
question are those are the universes
real this is really a question where you
have to pay attention to what you
actually mean by something being real
but the idea that particles have
additional physical properties whether
you call these additional Properties
proto-consciousness or something else is
a statement about physics so when
philosophers start doing physics then
they actually have to pay attention to
what the physics says this is also by
the way why I'm not a fan of the
simulation hypothesis this is another
section in my new book It suffers from
the same problem it makes big statements
about
um the fundamental laws of nature
without actually paying attention to
what we know about the fundamental laws
of nature so do particles think no
I think the overall story that I want to
tell with my book is that I think sign
and religion aren't at War there are a
lot of people who try to play those two
out against each other
but if you look at what's actually going
on in the foundations of physics that
then many of the ideas that physicists
consider there especially about
um the question how the universe began
they're basically extensions of some of
those originally religious or spiritual
ideas that just formulated uh in the
form of mathematics and there are many
of those
religious ideas which are still
compatible with with all we currently
know there are also some things that may
forever remain unknown I already said I
believe that ultimately we probably
won't be able to figure out how the
universe began because it seems to me
that this is just a way that science is
fundamentally limited that we we aren't
allowed to make a story more complicated
though that may not be wrong like there
may have been a more complicated
Universe before ours it's just that the
way that science works we would never be
able
um to say whether it was actually
correct
another question to which we may never
found find an answer is if there's
actually a theory of everything so this
isn't something which I talked about
here in any length again that's
something that I talk about in my book
um but to make a long story short the
problem is there will always remain the
question
for any Theory why this Theory we know
that the Universe has to be in some
particular way I mean we know that it is
some particular way and not any other so
we need a theory that agrees with what
what we observe but then there will
always be questions in this Theory which
we can only answer by saying because it
describes what we observe
so I think this is another way
um that science is fundamentally Limited
um scientists don't always mind this Gap
I think some of the examples that I gave
you show this very clearly that
sometimes they stray over into a room
where actually the methods of science
fail and they don't always notice
okay so this brings me back to my book
so I'm pretty much done I hope you
enjoyed this little talk there are more
questions in my book and you can find
more information on my website
existentialphysics.com thank you for
your attention
thank you
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV